So turns out if we want
to understand td lambda,
a really useful of studying it
is by studying naught td lambda.
So in particular, we're going to look
at k step estimators for a moment and
then we're going to relate
that back to td lambda.
So here what a k step estimator is.
So let's say, if we're trying to
estimate the value of a state, st.
So it's a state that we just are leaving
as a function of what happens next.
So let's look at this
first estimator here.
It says that we're going to estimate
the value of a state that we're leaving
by moving it a little bit in
the direction of the immediate reward
plus the discounted estimated value
of the state that we landed in.
And we're going to just move
a little bit in that direction.
So, do you recognize this?
Have you seen this before?
>> I believe I have seen this before.
>> What do we call it?
>> I don't remember anymore.
>> Oh, well that's fortunate.
>> But I've seen it before,
it's just like a one step
look ahead sort of thing.
>> Yeah,
exactly which is what we're calling td0.
>> All right.
Yes, yes, that makes sense.
>> And in fact, you're exactly right.
That the way to think about is
there's a one step estimator.
So it's a one step estimator.
In that, we'll use the immediate
reward that we got plus the value of
the state that we land in.
But let's contrast that
with a two-step estimator.
We call it e2.
Estimator 2,
where what we do is to estimate
the value of a state that we're leaving.
We're going to move a little bit int he
direction of the immediate reward that
we received, plus the discounted
reward that we receive next, plus
the double discounted value of the state
that we landed in two steps from now.
So now instead of where we were before,
we did an estimate by taking one reward.
And we estimate the rest of the sequence
using our current estimates.
Here we're taking two rewards, and using
that as our immediate estimate plus
our estimate of the future taken as the
state that we reach two steps from now.
So does that make sense kind of
as an extension of that idea?
>> It not only makes sense though,
if e1 is at one-step look ahead,
then e2 is two-step look ahead.
>> Yeah.
Yeah exactly.
So we used two steps,
two real steps followed by
this kind of look ahead thing.
And we can do that for
three, right here.
And we can do that for k, where we're
estimating the value of a state
by k rewards summed up here, plus and
then we estimate the value of the future
by looking at the state we end up in
k steps from now, and
discounting that by k steps.
And in fact,
if we continue doing this arbitrarily,
we eventually get to e infinity.
Where, let's see what would
happen int that case.
So we get the sum of rewards, and
it keeps going and it keeps going.
And eventually at infinity, we look at
the state that we end up at infinity,
which of course, isn't a real thing.
But then, it's okay, because we
discounted by gamma to the infinity,
which is zero.
So this piece of the term
actually drops out, and
we just end up with this
infinite sum of rewards.
Now, this last estimator should
look familiar to you too, Charles.
>> Yeah, that looks like td1.
>> Good!
So now we've got td0 on the one side,
as a one step estimator and
td1 on the other side,
as an infinity step estimator.
And we've got these other things in
between that we don't really have or
possibly even need a name for.
>> Well, that makes a lot more sense
than with the title k-step estimators.
I was worried this was
going to turn in some kind of.
Commentary about dub step.
>> Oh, yes, break it down.
So that's not going to
happen in this case.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's probably for the best.
>> So what I need to do next is actually
relate these quantities to td lambda
which we're going to show is a weighted
combination of all these estimators.
>> All infinity of them?
>> All infinity of them.
>> Oh, that's pretty impressive.